Michael il va comment il est toujours
dans le coma il a une opération
l'indique a duré trois heures il a fini
Morangis cérébrale
et donc il est toujours dans le coma il
s'est pas réveillé
est-ce qu'il est encore entre la vie et
la mort ou là toujours il est toujours
dans le coma donc oui
pour l'instant il devrait se réveiller
normalement mercredi jeudi mais pour
l'instant il y a rien
alors tout s'est déroulé samedi donc à
Sainte-Soline Michael était très engagé
contre les bassines de sainte Soline
oui en fait c'est un gamin pacifiste
c'est un gamin qui aimait qui aimait
rigolé qui est méchanceté et qui
accompagnait les manifestants pour pour
les soutenir mais c'est pas un bagarreur
enfin moi je le connais depuis qu'il est
tout jeune et c'est régulièrement sur de
manifestations pas du tout comment il
faisait régulièrement ce genre de dos
oui ça fait deux ans avec sa maman donc
Nathalie ma belle-sœur qui faisait les
manifestations et il lui a jamais rien
arrivé alors il a été touché au coup par
un projectile d'où venait ce projectile
c'est qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en fait
maintenant mais en fait donc il était
dans dans la troupe en fait avec les
magnifiques manifestants et c'est pris
une balle en fait au niveau de la tête
et il est tombé au sol pas de réaction
et en fait ils ont pas pu venir le
chercher puisque la enfin les gens qui
étaient sur place la gendarmerie et
autres avaient l'ordre de ne pas faire
venir justement le corps médical donc il
est resté longtemps allongé au sol
l'après-midi il a été transporté
justement à l'hôpital et il est tombé
dans le coma dans la nuit de dimanche à
lundi on sait pas qu'il a touché
c'est pas mise à part enfin qui aurait
ce genre
d'outils
en caoutchouc et extérieur caoutchouc
ouais voilà c'est ça alors qu'au départ
il se rend pas compte qu'il est
gravement touché
non il tombe il tombe en fait il a pas
vu venir le truc donc aucune réaction
imaginez-vous Cyril vous prenez un truc
comme ça il va se rendre de lui-même à
l'hôpital
non non
réussi à pénétrer à un moment donné et
qu'ils l'ont quand même emmené parce que
plein de gens s'affolaient autour en
fait il va être opéré du cerveau donc il
a été opéré lundi et une opération qui a
duré trois heures
et ensuite on est sa santé va se
dégrader c'est ce qui se dit et il est
donc comme vous l'avez dit plongé dans
un coma artificiel
aujourd'hui
on voulait connaître le profil de
Michael vous avez dit qu'il participait
souvent à ce genre de manifestations
pour nous qui ne le connaissons pas
c'est qui est Michael il faisait quoi
Michael dans la vie alors Michael
il faisait des petits boulots d'intérim
il est papa d'un petit garçon de 11 ans
Matteo 11 ans Michael a 33 ans il fera
34 ans le 20 novembre
et donc il faisait des petits boulots il
habitait à côté de chez sa maman c'est
sa maman donc la mamie qui s'occupait du
petit quand il travaillait et c'était un
gamin enfin c'est parce que bon il est
toujours présent j'espère qu'il le sera
pour longtemps c'est un gamin qui qui
oui qui était calme quoi c'est qui
n'était pas dans
dans la violence à aller attaquer qui
que ce soit
c'est un gamin plutôt calme comme les
jeunes diraient même perchés pour vous
dire tellement il était calme quoi
justement là je me tourne vers Bruno
Poma parce que selon certaines sources
et des gens disent qui Michael étaient
déjà connu des services de renseignement
quoi oui oui je pense pourquoi c'est
sorti dans la presse d'ailleurs il y a
eu des informations qui a été donné la
presse comme une activité mais comme l'a
dit Madame il était connu pour aller sur
les manifestivas gilets jaunes et autres
bon ça a été reconnu et même soi-disant
un petit passé mais ce qui ne justifie
pas ce qu'il est arrivé évidemment de
vendeur de SUP semble-t-il ça c'est les
éléments qui sont factuels mais les
bêtises
actuellement ce que je sais moi ce qui
m'interpelle à ce que vous dites madame
c'est que ce garçon était donc la
manifestation est-ce qu'il est avec les
manifestants il était avec les
manifestants et lesquelles manifestants
ceux qui étaient dans le pas ceux qui
provoquait il était dans le côté
justement pacifiste
généralement et vous savez ce qui s'est
passé on l'a vu en images on a vu
avant-hier encore les images étaient
très dures les gendarmes ont riposé de
façon considérable pour éviter que les
assaillants c'est ça le terme viennent
au contact de des gendarmes pour en
venir aux mains parce que
systématiquement on serait on se
retrouve comme dans les tranché en 14-18
je dirais si il y a pas les gendarmes
qui repoussent avec les LBD comme ils
l'ont fait etc c'est la charpie
c'est-à-dire on va au contact et là on
risque on risque même des mots
s'il a été dans le gros des manifestants
je m'étonne qu'il ait été impacté et ça
c'est juste une question on va voir avec
l'enquête ce que ça va donner très
sincèrement je suis interpellé par cet
élément là voilà c'est ce que je voulais
vous dire deuxièmement pour l'évacuation
parliez d'évacuation un peu difficile il
faut savoir parce que on en a parlé tout
aujourd'hui j'entendais dans les médias
que les secours n'ont pas pu arriver
qu'on ne voulait pas que du coup arrive
alors c'est totalement cette histoire
c'est totalement faux euh cyrilia une
procédure qui est mis en place par le
préfet le patron de la sécurité d'un
site comme ça c'est le préfet c'est pas
les hommes qui a révélé ça oui oui ou la
Ligue des droits de l'homme qui dit au
revoir envoyer 20 observateurs en fait
c'est pas eux qui font la sécurité
tentative de le travail de sécurité est
fait par le préfet ça c'est clair et les
autorités de gendarmerie qui sont
présentes et de police qui avait des CRS
qui assurent effectivement la sécurité
du site et qui décide à un moment donné
si on doit envoyer le secours ou pas
pourquoi je vous dis ça parce que
envoyer un hélicoptère c'est impossible
on peut pas poser un hélicoptère dans
une zone pareille c'est une zone de
guerre c'est impossible de poser
pourquoi parce qu'il faut des policiers
ou des gendarmes pour assurer la
sécurité non seulement de l'hélicoptère
mais en même temps des secours et
sachant que les secours comme les les
gendarmes immunitaires sont pris à
partie souvent et bien la problématique
l'attente qui a eu 45 minutes on dit eh
bien ça a été décidé par le directeur
médical et le préfet de dire stop on
attend que la situation s'apaise pour
pouvoir intervenir Gilles sauf que Bruno
il y a quand même deux questions qui se
posent d'abord on parle de LBD donc
lanceur de défend pris et la question
qui se pose c'est que il y a des
gendarmes sur des quads qui aurait tiré
des balles de LBD non appropriées
d'ailleurs il y a deux enquêtes ouvertes
donc quand on se déplace sur un quad
peut-être qu'on peut avoir un tir qui va
sans doute involontairement bien sûr
mais blesser quelqu'un qui n'est pas aux
premières loges parce que on voit les
images derrière Cyril des quad on peut
difficilement viser sur les poissons
on a les enregistrements bien entendu du
Samu dans les vidéos du sonore s'amuse
que plusieurs médias ont d'ailleurs
accès à des enregistrements assez
compromettants au téléphone avec le SAMU
on comprend qu'ils allaient ils disent
qu'ils auraient reçu des ordres de ne
pas intervenir on va écouter ça
vous avez vous en êtes où là de la plus
grosse urgence absolue de de ce que j'ai
comme impression moi de loin
sur place si on lui a expliqué la
situation c'est qu'on enverra pas à ces
micro haut de moyens pure sur place
parce qu'on a en plein temps d'envoyer
sur les portes de l'ordre alors moi je
suis avec des observateurs de la Ligue
des droits de l'homme qui disent que les
observateurs sur place disent que c'est
calme depuis 30 minutes et que donc il
est possible d'intervenir
des forces de l'ordre et
qu'on est
encore une fois l'appréciation du préfet
des forces de l'ordre qui sont
directeurs de la sécurité directeur des
services médicaux sur place et qui
décident que le médecin n'a pas à
prendre de risques maintenant la Ligue
des droits de l'homme qui nous dit que
30 minutes de battements moi je veux
bien voir je veux entendre tout le monde
mais écoutez excusez-moi c'est à chaque
fois le même cinéma d'ailleurs c'est la
Ligue des droits de l'Homme et la police
en face moi je crois plutôt les forces
de l'ordre parce que le préfet a une
vraie responsabilité même pénale de pas
porter à 600 à un blesser donc ça c'est
une chose évidente et ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure la complexité
d'intervenir sur un site pareil est très
très compliqué et la décision à prendre
est très compliquée aussi pour les pour
les autres
la France le monde c'est pas ça c'est
pas Sandrine c'est pas des
manifestations interdites Sandrine
excusez moi c'est arrivé à un moment ils
font ce qu'ils font on est d'accord que
ça doit bien se passer ça se passe mal
maintenant lui il était dans la il
soutenez les manifestants il se prend un
truc il le calcule pas on le voit à
terre tout le monde hurle autour et on
laisse sortir comme ça et pour protéger
le corps médical on va pas sauver un
humain on prend pas de risque eux ils en
prennent tous les jours
ils en prennent les manifestants il faut
pas lire manifestations
la manifestation est interdite je vais
vous dire une chose c'est très factuel
si cette manifestation devait bien se
passer elle aurait été organisée les
responsables ce sont l'association écolo
qui avait il y a également
la Fondation qu'on appelle ça les
agriculteurs
plutôt agriculteurs de gauche qui était
présent il y a également les élus qui
étaient présents des députés de la
République était sur une manifestation
éternité excusez-moi si tous ces hommes
là c'était entendu avant allez voir le
préfet et organiser une manifestation
madame tout ça se serait pas la même
ne vient pas
le problème ne vient pas de là il est
déjà d'avant le problème il vient pas de
là le problème
la tristesse de
son neveu on va entendre d'ailleurs un
premier audio de la maman de Michael qui
nous ont dit un peu plus sur l'état de
santé de son fils et sur les possibles
c'est qu'elle écoutait
avec l'opération bon il est plus il est
plus en pronostic engagé déjà maintenant
il est toujours
coma artificiel donc il lui descend de
la dose un petit peu par petit peu donc
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui il est pas
encore réveillé alors les séquelles on
peut pas en parler pour le moment tant
qu'il est pas réveillé et savent pas du
tout s'il aura des séquelles ou pas des
séquelles en attendant il a une
cervicale qui est facturée donc il l'ont
mis avec une Minerve
on a d'autres sonores de maman vous
entendez
quand même c'est qui peut vous être là
je suis la tata de Mickaël la sœur de la
belle-sœur mon frère qui est avec
Nathalie
Sandrine quand vous entendez Bruno
Pommard qui
qui voilà qui qui vous dit que bien sûr
il est il est triste pour pour
évidemment pour votre neveu mais qui dit
voilà il fallait pas venir à cette
manifestation lui dites quoi mais c'est
ce que je lui ai dit il a pas le droit
de dire ça
ils ont pas y aller elle n'est pas
autorisée madame mais excusez-moi je
suis au République moi je suis une merde
depuis quand on est autorisé
mais toujours depuis quand les
manifestations sont on demande une
autorisation pour faire une
manifestation quelle qu'elle soit c'est
tout oui on est d'accord
ça serait si les gens aujourd'hui c'est
ce qu'on veut dans ce pays donc arrivé à
un moment ils sont partis faire ce que
beaucoup n'ont pas été faire mais
aujourd'hui on n'est pas dans le droit
de les critiquer cette manifestation
aurait dû être organisée je suis pas
contre l'organisation le fait qu'elle se
passe mais elle doit être organisée
c'est de la faute de la Confédération
paysanne des associations écolos des
élus qui étaient présents des députés
République escadaleux si ces gens-là
avaient pris leur responsabilité tout ça
ne se serait pas passé voilà ce que je
vous dis moi je suis républicain je suis
comme ça peut-être ce que je veux même
si c'est organisé rien même s'organiser
rien n'est respecté parce que ça part
toujours en cacahuète non les
manifestations à Paris se sont très bien
passé on les services des syndicats je
voudrais avoir une pensée excuse-moi
Cyril de le dire une pensée là j'ai eu
la gendarmerie nationale est quand même
parce que c'est vrai que les oublie je
suis d'accord qu'on fasse un focus sur
sur ce garçon pourquoi pas 48 blessés
assez grave deux un état d'urgence
absolue ils sont sortis aujourd'hui sont
un état d'urgence relative je voudrais
penser à eux parce que eux assurés juste
l'heure de public ils étaient pas là
pour en prendre soin de la gueule
excusez-moi mais on est d'accord mais la
question justement c'est pourquoi
pourquoi la police se révolte pourquoi
on en est arrivé aujourd'hui
avec les ordres qu'on nous implique
aujourd'hui et ça fait boule de neige la
police c'est pareil ils n'ont pas
forcément de protection pour pouvoir te
soutien si vous voulez donc ça fait
boule de neige et un embarquement
il y avait alors je ne sais pas où se
trouvait votre neveu s'il était avec
ceux qui allaient ou comme vous dites en
retrait et que et que voilà et qu'il a
pris un LBD perdu mais effectivement on
peut avoir et penser à ses forces de
l'ordre qui était là et qui eux étaient
sous le feu de projectiles divers et
variés et pas des plus sympathiques et
qui on a vu c'était un déluge de trucs
qui sont pas partis à l'assaut
apparemment il y a pas eu de trucs
offensifs c'était essentiellement
défensif donc évidemment c'est
extrêmement
c'est compliqué de toute façon c'est
compliqué et c'est pas parce que je
subis et que je parle au nom de ma
belle-sœur que je ne comprends pas non
plus ce qui se passe à côté les pompiers
ils en prennent plein la pleine poumons
ils sont pas protégés je comprends je
peux comprendre tout ça et je peux tout
entendre mais il y a des choses que je
ne peux pas accepter vous savez que sur
il fallait pas y aller c'est une chose
qu'il fallait pas alors on a les sonores
comme je vous l'ai dit on a eu la maman
de Michael au téléphone qu'on va vous
faire écouter un deuxième sonore elle
nous indique que son fils était un
manifestant comme vous l'avez dit
Sandrine totalement pacifiste
son drapeau mais voilà c'est pas un
casseur tu as un tableau c'est un simple
manifestant
elle revient aussi parce qu'on en parle
actuellement et on en parle avec Bruno
Poma notamment elle revient aussi sur la
manière dont les forces de l'ordre on
réagit écouter
ils ont pas fait de la prévention les
flics les flics ils étaient là-bas pour
faire du massacre sur les manifestants
c'est de la castagne de manifestants
qu'il fallait qu'il fasse un c'est tout
déjà d'où on tire à LBD dans le cou d'un
gamin ou d'une personne de toute manière
c'est ce qu'ils font aussi à Paris même
quand on fait rien donc à partir de là
il y a pas photo c'est pas les
manifestants qui vont chercher les flics
c'est les filles qui vont chercher les
manifestants de toute manière la plainte
a été déposée elle est au parquet de
Rennes
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à la maman
de Michael bah tout est dit je veux pas
la câbler je comprends qu'elle défendre
son fils à tout prix mais mais c'est
c'est pathétique et l'internauter le
parole écoutez excusez-moi elle est
touchée
ne sont acharnés sur les manifestants
c'est faux les policiers les gendarmes
ce sont défendus oui il faut il faut me
les images sont là pour parler les
drones également sur la peau parlé donc
si vous voulez regarder regarde mais
regardez je dirais que ce sont descendus
parce que les gens
c'est factuel je veux dire c'est des
images voilà je veux bien qu'on ait des
travers la police on le sait tout le
monde sait et ils sont sanctionnés mais
voilà il faut pas rajouter je comprends
cette dame sont désarroi mais voilà
encore une fois la police travailler
dans un cadre républicain à chaque fois
qu'elle le peut s'il y a des s'il y a
des dérapages il y a des bavures elles
sont sanctionnées c'est le cas avec la
brave ce qui s'est passé avec la Brava à
Paris il y a quelques temps il y a une
enquête en cours ils vont être sûrement
sanctionnés ou pas je sais pas si c'est
avéré voilà mais je le comprends la
seule chose où je vais changer votre
phrase je ne vais pas généraliser comme
partout je ne vais pas généraliser qui
est certaines personnes qui
effectivement sont bons pour faire leur
travail ok mais on peut pas dire tous
les gendarmes tous les policiers ou
alors tous les pompiers c'est partout
pareil donc je ne peux pas généraliser
ça il y a forcément quelqu'un qui a fait
une erreur le gamin il a pris cher pour
rien vous devriez dire à votre à la
maman de Michael de porter plainte même
sur la côte
elle devrait porter plainte sur les
organisateurs
et tout ça c'est des oiseaux tout ça
incapable d'organiser une manif eux ont
des responsabilités je vous le dis la
Confédération paysanne a des
responsabilités l'association des
responsabilités les élus qui étaient
présents les députés qu'on écologie ont
des responsabilités c'est ce dans le moi
je vous le dis je suis maire
du cadre des problèmes
parce que il y avait rien d'organiser
sûrement il doit y avoir
regardez-moi mais non
vous avez eu du bol
ça s'est bien passé il y a eu les gros
piscicules comme d'habitude avec on a vu
d'ailleurs les bras en images ça c'était
très intéressant de voir comment
travailler la police ça c'était
intéressant de voir comment travailler
les bras et les compagnies
d'intervention ça c'est très intéressant
de voir ça permet un peu de de casser un
petit peu le stéréotype qu'on a de la
police et qui est là que pour se fritter
avec les gars non c'est pas vrai et la
manifestation s'est passée oui il y a eu
des attentats
je vous rappelle vous pouvez pas
mettre la protection et vous dire quel
député ou vous-même sera dans le danger
comme ce petit c'est pas les mêmes
protections c'est pas les mêmes
démarches c'est même pas comparable
comme vous dites il y a des députés vous
voulez que je puisse
vous Sandrine est-ce que vous en voulez
au députés aux organisateurs de la manif
ou pas du tout en fait j'en veux à la
violence que tous ces gens provoquent
que ce soit citoyen comme la police
comme les gendarmes j'en veux à la
violence générale en fait je suis pas là
pour blâmer qui que ce soit je suis là
pour essayer de faire justice en fait
les responsables sont les organisateurs
et les députés les gens de d'Europe
c'est le fait qui disait que les députés
aussi prenaient du danger enfin
été soumis pardon au danger et au reste
non je peux pas l'entendre parce qu'il a
dit
qu'ils étaient responsable des
cautionner une manifestations qui
étaient interdit excusez-moi
et je pense que pour des des
je crois ici au taux de la table voilà
pour vous c'est aussi les les vous dites
que les les organisateurs et les députés
européens écologiques qui se sont rendus
sur cette manifestation ont une
responsabilité c'est ce que disait Bruno
Pommard quand vous l'entendez dire ça
est-ce que vous trouvez qu'ils ont une
responsabilité ou est-ce que vous pensez
que voilà c'est c'est c'est c'est juste
les forces de l'autre con une
responsabilité dans le dans ce que je
pense au fond de moi bah ici vous pouvez
me dire je vais rester poli mais j'en ai
rien à faire parce que pour moi c'est
que du vent
je suis complètement d'accord avec elle
aussi c'est des gugusses même les
députés qui sont allés c'est juste pour
faire du buzz voilà nickel qui est allé
lui il croit en son truc il y va voilà
il y va parce que il croit en son truc
il défend une cause les gugus c'est
députés qui sont allés là-bas les
Guignols là qui sont partis derrière ils
ont cautionnés
[Musique]
en profite encore une fois pour nous
poser
c'est intéressant mais oui il faut bien
nourrir la vie des journalistes c'est
moi qui va aller avec les journalistes
non vous irez tous plus que moi en tout
cas pas moi c'est pour ça que j'ai fait
comme ça j'ai pas fait comme ça
qui que ce soit je suis pas là pour
dénoncer qui que ce soit je suis pas là
pour insulter quelque chose quoi je suis
là en tant que tente de Michael qui est
dans le coma qui risque de laisser un
gamin parce qu'on dit que c'est pas
engagé en attendant il s'est pas
réveillé il y a une opération très
lourde donc moi je ne crois pas ni les
médecins ni les médias ni rien quand il
sera debout je le croirais donc
aujourd'hui il risque de laisser un
gamin de 11 ans d'accord
et sur sa grand-mère et c'est tonton et
ses tata ce petit voilà donc aujourd'hui
on me dit les préfets et les chaises et
les cela il faut nourrir les
journalistes monsieur non mais moi je
vous parle du cœur il y aurait plus de
boulot demain je vous parle du cadre
tout simplement ben non comment ça
s'organise ce qu'il faut faire et ne pas
faire exactement
l'expression c'est le bordel partout on
évite des problèmes si c'est
organisément Sandrine juste dans dans ce
que vous dites là c'est vrai que
vous vous dites aussi que ces
organisateurs c'est voilà c'est ces
personnes qui qui qui appelle les gens à
sortir dans la rue qui sont pas en
première ligne forcément c'est c'est
problématiques et je le dis moi je le
dis franchement moi je vous le dis c'est
député qui était derrière et comme elle
l'a dit Sandrine qui risque rien qui
sont derrière dans le cortège et quand
on voit des Mickey et autres voilà au
front parce que ils défendent une vraie
cause et qui se retrouvent après dans le
coma ça pour moi
tout le monde pour la provocation il y
en a pas un pour rattraper l'autre de
toute façon que ce soit journaliste que
ce soit préférée ou je sais pas quoi le
journaliste mais en l'occurrence
on est d'accord mais encore une fois
j'avais pas une généralité il y a des
bons comme il y a des mauvais comme dans
tout le corps de métier oui mais là je
vois pas bien le rapport sur
journaliste parce que voilà je me suis
peut-être mal exprimé et pardon va les
risques que je veux dire mais je vous en
prie je parle en général c'est la tente
de Michael on a le droit de la laisser
dire ce qu'elle dit et Sandrine
aujourd'hui elle parle avec le cœur
voilà moi je vais vous dire voilà
merci d'avoir été là on pense qu'à une
chose c'est Mickaël sa famille sa femme
c'est sa petite fille voilà et vraiment
et on pense à la à la maman de Michael
et Sandrine vous avez été formidable et
on comprend votre peine votre tristesse
et franchement moi je vous kiffe en tout
cas voilà
quand on est là pour faire la guerre
j'en ai rien à [__] de faire la guerre
en fait moi ce que je veux c'est sauver
ce petit et mise à part venir là parce
que Nathalie n'a pas pu je ne peux pas
faire autre chose de mieux donc oui ça
vous plaît pas et je m'en excuse tout ça
du public et de vous tous mais je ne
peux pas faire autrement
pour parler de la manifestation
avec le coeur et c'est l'essentiel merci
d'avoir été là merci beaucoup merci son
nom merci beaucoup merci beaucoup c'est
nous qui vous remercions Sandrine et
voilà moi j'aime les gens qui parlent
avec le coeur et qui qui parlent vrai et
voilà vous êtes moi vous faites partie
des gens voilà que que que voilà des des
des des des attitudes que j'aime qui
apprécie j'en ai marre des mythos et des
mecs voilà des citoyens voilà c'est ça
moi c'est ce que et c'est pour ça que
que voilà j'aime comment vous parler et
j'aime comment vous exprimer ce que vous
dites voilà après
on va tellement de mytho que on commence
en avoir à le cul et vous voilà vous
êtes vrai et c'est problème c'est que je
peux ajouter quelque chose ou pas le
problème c'est que mon enfin il y a des
mots moi qui me qui passent pas en fait
on parle d'organisation dans les
manifestations
regardez l'état du monde rien n'est
organisé vous croyez que le monde va
bien rien n'est organisé là on est sur
les manifestations et pardonnez-moi
c'est peut-être hors sujet mais il y a
des mots comme ça quand on me parle
d'organisation vous savez ce que ça veut
dire organiser on parle des manifs mais
on est obligé d'en arriver là rien n'est
organisé le monde va mal donc on attend
que Michael soit dans le coma pour dire
ah si c'était organisé peut-être ça se
passerait pas comme ça c'est la faute
des autres le fait d'accuser quelqu'un
ça disculpabilise l'autre c'est facile
pour l'État c'est parce que j'ai dit la
Sandrine
vous avez très bien expliqué les choses
et je vous dis on peut pas un moment il
y a pas que où les forces de l'ordre ou
les manifestants qui sont responsables
aussi c'est ça le problème c'est qu'à un
moment là en ce moment c'est où les
manifestants les forces de l'ordre
attention je pense que c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué que ça c'est beaucoup
plus complexe que ça et je pense que les
forces dehors elles font des choses qui
qui les peines et je peux vous dire que
quand elles vont au charbon elles sont
exactement et les manifestants